all right we are now live for the
February AMA that's ask me anything
session we've already got some good
questions lined up so I may as well just
uh jump in and start addressing them I
will say that it's nice to be inside
today it's pretty cold out here in
Milwaukee and I've got my good Stone
Creek Coffee here so all right so let's
let's look at the first one lapse nine
Continuum I heard you say that you
studied math and college I'm fascinated
by the notion of limits there seem to be
natural joints or singularities in
nature and time emergence thoughts so
yeah interestingly enough
the theory of limits was part of what
got me to study mathematics as a
discipline in college in part because I
think like a lot of people in middle and
high school math was pretty boring
um you know I was good at it but I
didn't see
any real you know sort of
deep significance to it and the Math
teachers were pretty dull types you know
um so anyway I got to college and I
tested well in my SATs and um
they threw me into a Calculus class
and so the very first day the professor
Ron Haas started explaining the theory
of limits and most of the class were
bored out of their minds because they
weren't into that sort of thing and I
was like watching him put stuff on the
board and I was like holy crap this is
math this is not like math that I've
encountered before this is really cool
stuff and so I went up to him afterwards
and I had a question for him and his
eyes lit up and I was asking about like
well you know when you go to Infinity on
one side or the other would they like
coincide with each other and and you
know we got to talking about infinity
and infinitesimals and so the theory of
limits actually played a real important
role in getting me to be interested in
that and then I just kept taking more
and more math classes
as well as you know uh majoring in
philosophy so then at a certain point I
was like well I may as well major in
mathematics too
so I double majored in in college now
you know are there limits in a
non-mathematical sense like a
metaphysical sense yeah I mean Aristotle
talks about this uh and so do other
authors an ancient philosophy and
um yeah Are there natural joints you
mean places where things separate out
for you know no longer this thing now
this thing in nature certainly appears
so because otherwise we couldn't exist
right and we are if you think about the
human body we are these very complex
Dynamic systems which actually
incorporate a lot of stuff that's not
human body inside of us like you know
all these micro you know biomes that we
have in our guts and you know chemicals
floating around in our our bloodstream
and brains and things like that so yeah
there's there's all sorts of uh
limits where you cross a threshold from
one thing to another and philosophers
have been you know quite interested in
that
um how do you explain you know movement
interpenetration those sorts of things I
don't do that much with that myself but
there's there's many other philosophers
who are quite interested in that so
let me take Dr beavis's more serious
question because there is no such thing
as the best breakfast meal there's no
best meal at all
um so Dr biva says If ghosts were real
what ghosts would you like to hang out
with
so it's good that it doesn't say most
like to hang out with
so I probably would want to hang out
with you know ghosts of family members
and maybe friends who have died
um over the course of my lifetime I you
know my father died when I was only 11
and he was 36 so we never got to have an
adult relationship an adult a
relationship between adults
um so there's lots of things I would
have loved to talk with him about as a
matter of fact we were at an amazing
concert performance
just two nights ago here in Milwaukee
Winston Marcellus
had his like whole Jazz Ensemble and I
forget the guy's name but he's like a
master of the Ood and they've been
collaborating together for 15 years and
it was just an amazing concert
performance and my dad would have loved
it and I would have loved to have been
able to talk with him about it but
that's just not you know feasible you
can chat with the memory that you have
in your head but at this point I'm way
older than he ever was and you know I'd
love to see my mom again
um there are pets who I miss
particularly sassy but also our two dogs
and Sassy's sister Teensy and my other
cats that I've had and dogs in the
course of my life and you know I miss my
grandparents
my grandpa and grandma lambre's more
than my grandpa Sadler but Grandma
Sadler died when I was only seven and
you know so I think for me the ghosts
would be you know people I've been
connected with so that's kind of a cool
question
uh Alexander Oland uh
if you had to remove Three Philosophers
from history the world will explode if
you don't which ones would you choose
um you know that's a great question I I
probably would go looking for
non-entities who wouldn't particularly
be missed I'd take kind of a utilitarian
perspective on this you know I don't
have any like oh I hate their guts I
wish they were completely dead the way
that some people do in relation to
certain philosophers
um I I kind of think that I would try to
find the people who would have the least
impact you know not only that they
didn't make any impact in philosophy but
you know nobody in their neighborhood
would miss them they don't have family
or
you know anything like that that that
would be my guess uh Ali says any advice
on how to read classic philosophical
texts they seem really hard to read at
times
you just got to keep at it I mean I've
got those videos on self-directed study
that I think give you some advice I've
got a video on reading philosophical
texts there isn't a recipe for how to do
it there's all sorts of approaches that
you can take but I guess the thing
that's the most important is to not
allow the discouragement yeah they're
going to be hard to read just like going
to the gym and working out is hard but
it's rewarding if you keep doing it
you'll you'll you know it will get
easier but philosophical texts are never
going to be completely effortless and
they probably shouldn't be so
and Andy Olivia says do you have any
thoughts on mere civility by Theresa
Baja and I've been seeing it come up a
lot lately not even on my radar I I
haven't heard about it but that doesn't
you know have anything to say about
whether it's a good book or not because
there are literally thousands of
philosophy books published every year
and um most of us only see a few of them
um so I I don't have any connection with
it
Bill Beau Baggins if you had to
recommend one famous Wisconsin beer to a
tourist which uh beer from Wisconsin
would you suggest so that's a great
question I mean I wouldn't recommend
um the American pilsners that tended to
be what made you know Milwaukee so
famous like Pabst Blue Ribbon or Miller
um or uh you know hams or these sorts of
things because they're not very good you
know we drank that crap when we were
younger because we didn't know any
better I mean they're better than
Budweiser right which is complete crap
but there's so many great beers and I
would recommend
um some beers from the sprecker brewery
here in Milwaukee one of the oldest
microbrewer craft breweries
microbreweries around
um their stuff was available when I was
you know in high school and I started
drinking it probably when I was 19 or
20.
um definitely after I was 21 my mom
actually had my 21st birthday
brought me a four pack of sprecker's
black Bavarian
and that was like real good beer you
know
um and they have a lot of cool stuff
they also make root beer uh so
non-alcoholic and cream soda and I think
an orange sickle but they have these you
know black Bavarian is a short Spear and
uh but a you know Milwaukee version of
it they've got a great Amber they've got
a cool Oktoberfest they've got all sorts
of other stuff so I would say sprecker I
you know what I wouldn't get anybody
there's this big hype around
um this one beer that uh
uh
they have a great marketing strategy but
their beer isn't really that good and
the marketing strategy is you can't buy
it outside of Wisconsin right
um
and I'm forgetting the the actual oh uh
spot is it Spotted Cow they make like
moon man and stuff like that their stuff
just ain't that good you know
um sprecker is where it's at all right
um
let's see Ali Awad what philosophies
have you got the most benefits from like
stoicism for mental resilience I mean in
part the ones that you see me engaging
with the most so you know ancient
philosophies the platonist tradition
which means not just Plato but running
through Plutarch and middle platonists
and into the neoplatonists uh the stoic
tradition the Aristotelian tradition
thinkers like Cicero who are eclectics
various Christian thinkers like climate
of Alexandria lactancias or Augustine or
you know boethius
existentialists of all different sorts
dialectical philosophers like Hegel you
know all running all the way up to
people like Lecom so there's a there's a
whole bunch of of people who I drawn and
that's part of why I'm an Eclectic I
don't think we have to be on team such
and such you know and I think that you
know to take stoicism it's become very
popular but many of the of people who
claim to be stoics
aren't really stoics because they don't
spend time reading stoic texts and like
learning about stoicism so you know that
seems like a little bit of a a problem
to me
um you know that they're on team
stoicism but they don't know much about
it I am this try to clean this lens a
little bit that's a little better I was
seeing this line coming through things
um
Patrick says what do you think of the
Rose Walden would you consider making a
video on thoreau's works yeah I would I
would consider doing Walden I'd also
consider his um I forget exactly what
it's called but he's got this great like
in Praise of John Brown because you know
through Rose and abolitionist and uh
being an abolitionist essentially meant
you know
taking a hard stand at a difficult time
that had to do with human dignity uh and
uh being against slavery in this state
by the way Wisconsin most anti-slavery
state in the nation at the time that uh
the Civil War was was being fought so
um yeah I would I would do Thoreau you
know the the trouble is is that I'm not
usually shooting core concept videos on
people who I'm not teaching in my
classes and I don't usually teach
through well you know there's nothing
that says I couldn't right in some class
down the line
uh Brian uh has a good question here
about Lecom
[Music]
um
best way to start with lacam so
I actually do have some opinions about
this
best way to start is not by jumping into
the acree the accre is this wonderful
collection of really important essays
that people
um reference like you know the mirror
stage or you know that sort of stuff but
that stuff is a little bit trickier than
what goes on in his seminars and I
wouldn't necessarily start with seminar
one and two although it wouldn't hurt
you to do that but I actually you know I
often suggest people start with the
ethics of psychoanalysis in part because
there's like reference points that
you're getting you're getting to see
like Hans take on say you know romantic
love or utilitarianism or decide or Kant
or you know Aristotle or people like
that and I think it if you've got a bit
of a background in philosophy that might
be the easiest way to to go in
um Ollie after stoicism what philosophy
do you recommend to study who says you
have to wait until after stoicism I mean
it's not like you can exhaust reading
philosophy you have to go back like with
any great philosophy and reread and
study some more deep in your approach
and stuff like that it's so I would put
aside the after
um and just think about what it is that
you're attracted to there's nothing that
says you have to like go back and begin
with Plato or pre-socratics you know
um you can jump into Aristotle and the
Aristotelian tradition if you want you
can jump forward in time and read Renee
Descartes somebody influenced by the
stoics you can you know it's up to you
it's your brain you get to do what you
want with it
um
for the purposes of this question
where is the rest of chimchuri you can
consider Peterson a philosopher
I don't see the rest of the question
but I wouldn't dignify Peterson with the
title philosopher he's a guru type who
Blends together the stuff that he's read
sometimes inexpertly you know you can be
like well that's a terrible reading of
Nietzsche you know or
um where did this come from I think he
probably should have retired a couple
years ago he's done his thing he doesn't
have anything to contribute that's new
and the stuff that he does have to
contribute is kind of blah you know I
think people will look at him in in you
know future time and be like oh yeah
he's sort of like you know other
non-entities that we don't read anymore
but that was part of the popular culture
of the time you know so
lap says uh been studying calculus as
somebody with a Philosophy degree I've
had similar experiences being Charmed
and intrigued
a lot of cool stuff going on in
um in mathematics you know
if you think about the different
applications of it and then you know
well there's this whole thing called
philosophy of mathematics where we ask
questions like well what the hell are
numbers
you know and you could be a platonist or
an intuitionist or a formalist there's
all sorts of cool stuff going on and but
you can say that really with any
discipline right if you get it to the
higher levels of it you inevitably start
dealing with
um metaphysical questions moral
questions epistemological questions
aesthetic questions you know like when
you're doing proofs in mathematics why
do we like proofs to be elegant that's
an aesthetic question right so yeah
all right uh alionic has a very
practical question I've been talking to
someone online for two years in a few
months she will visit the UK and we will
meet I am worried that things will be
different when we meet in person any
advice well they definitely will be
different when you meet in person
because you're meeting in person and
you'll be spending time in ways that are
quite different
um so you know it's not whether or not
things will be different it's What
attitude do you want to adopt towards
the difference and you can worry if you
want to but you could also like embrace
it and be like holy crap it's uh so
awesome not seeing you on a screen but
actually here in real time in a place
with me right so Joy could be an option
Wonder could be an option if you like to
fight you can get angry at each other
that's another option right so I think
you should ask yourself why why is there
worry there I mean maybe what you mean
is that you're worried you're going to
be disappointed or you're worried that
they're going to be disappointed with
you there's going to be sort of negative
experiences and then you can think about
well why would that be the case you know
um you don't really know what it's going
to be like until you get together in the
room with them and you know I I would
like say you know try to keep your
expectations kind of low and that way
they can easily be satisfied and perhaps
you can go beyond them right
all right Scotland's um who do you think
has the greatest chance of winning the
Super Bowl
yeah you know I don't know I I would I
think I would put my money on the Eagles
but I don't really care once the Packers
and the other teams that I care about
the Bears and the Colts are out
I don't really care what happens you
know I don't have a proverbial dog in
that fight the Chiefs are a good team
Eagles are a good team
um
you know I'm just kind of happy Brady's
retiring uh because he's been around for
a long time and never liked that guy so
yeah all right Alexander says how would
you explain what philosophy is to
someone who's never heard of it before I
probably wouldn't explain it I probably
would um suggest that they read some you
know short pieces and then we could talk
about it I you know I mean you could say
things like well it's the love of wisdom
but what the hell does that actually
tell you you know not a lot so you know
that doesn't seem like a really great
strategy for conveying anything I mean I
do have videos that I provide my intro
students like in the first couple days
of class
saying philosophy is you know it's this
thing with a very long history
and it's a literature it's an it's a
kind of activity it's also you could say
a set of normative ideals that we try to
measure up to like being rational and
providing arguments and you know being
being well informed and you know not
distorting people's texts and stuff like
that
um and you know it's also a discipline
it's it's a place on campus in in
universities so it's all those things
all right Brian says
discovered you through your video on a
van votes the world of null a what other
van vote would you recommend and what
other pulpey sci-fi would you recommend
for philosophy and or religious studies
course well so van Vogt uh is famous for
null a he's also very famous for the
slan uh stories right so those are those
are quite good
um there's you know the weapon maker
series which I also did a session on
um and then he's got all sorts of other
stuff as well that's not quite so um
connected you could say and he's got
short stories that he writes
um and those are you know those are
quite good as well I'm I'm kind of I'm a
fan of Van vote um Damon Knight really
hated his guts and wrote terrible things
about him but I'm more of the Philip K
dick uh
appreciation of Van Gogh uh tendency
where you're like well yeah of course
his stories don't completely add up
because they're not supposed to be
logically consistent you know
um
so yeah and then what other pulpey
sci-fi would you recommend for for
philosophy or religious studies courses
I mean Asimov wrote pulp stuff right so
he's not a he's not a great writer in
some parts but he can be good Philip
Jose farmer you know uh great pulprider
of course we have all the horror weird
stuff with like Lovecraft as well
um CL Moore you know she was she was a
great writer as well back in that that
era working with sometimes her husband
Henry Kutner very closely
um there are some pieces where like it's
clearly both of them and it's hard to
disentangle them
I'll Sprague to Camp you know
um those are those are the people who
come to mind right off the bat and then
you know we also have like the pulp
detective stuff like I'm I'm a huge fan
of Raymond Chandler
um having started reading him a couple
years back pre-covet now that I think
about it because I remember getting the
books at the library
and wow do I do I like his stuff I think
I'd probably go back to them again
um
Luca have you tried any sci-fi books
intertwined with philosophical ideas
yes I have indeed tried some sci-fi
books intertwined with philosophical
ideas you might not know but I I
actually have a series that I've been
doing since 2016 called worlds of
speculative fiction
and uh the last two were on Dan Simmons
Hyperion novels
um which have a few philosophical themes
in them you could say
um so yeah I mean you can easily go
through and see which ones I'm I've been
uh particularly Keen to Grapple with and
not just sci-fi but also you know like
dystopian fiction fantasy weird horror
uh alternate history you know so yeah
all right Bruno uh how am I any favorite
Buddhist texts
um
no I I wouldn't say I have any favorite
Buddhist texts there are you know some
short ones that I I have my students
read like when we're doing
um world religions you know I I will say
this
Americans and maybe this also holds for
Europeans they often have a very
truncated and distorted viewpoint on
Buddhism
where it's you know there's like what
the Buddha said and so a few theravada
uh texts and then they jump right into
Zen Buddhism and then maybe you know
some Tibetan stuff or some engaged
Buddhism uh even secular Buddhism and
they ignore the majority of the let's
call it the normative tradition
so if you think about Mahayana Buddhism
um I mean to begin with it's different
from country to Country so you know
there's what's going on in India and in
Central Asia and then that crosses you
know the Himalayas famously or it goes
around it through Central Asia and makes
its way into China and you get all these
cool schools
um and Sean or Zen is one of them but
only one of them you also have all these
sort of metaphysical schools which uh
sometimes the Zen people will draw upon
and you have pure land jingtao you know
uh uh or you know uh the various
Japanese versions of pure land Buddhism
massively important you know I have
Buddhists in my family and
um they're not Zen Buddhists they're
pure land Buddhists because that's
that's quite common and we often don't
teach about that so you know I actually
have my students read some of the pure
land sutras and look at some of the art
artwork and architecture sure
um
you know and and so it's it's
different in how things develop in in
China where the different schools are
much more like drawing upon each other
and in Japan they're often opposed to
each other
um things happen differently and of
course in Vietnam and in Korea and then
if we think about like theravada and
Buddhism and Thailand and Sri Lanka you
know and then we get the uh uh we go we
get you know Mahayana and vajrayana
Buddhism in in Tibet and Mongolia
there's a vast panoply of stuff right
um
and so I I think it I don't really have
favorite texts I have texts that I
assign my students to try to give them a
fuller understanding of what is involved
in this vast you know Millennia old uh
philosophical and religious tradition
all right
um Patrick do you see any modern lessons
we could learn from French or Russian
anarchists
um for example krapotkan bakkunen prudon
I mean myself no because I'm not really
I don't think much about anarchism
um I'm not moving in those circles and
it's been years since I've read those
people so I I wouldn't be very competent
to say anything about that
uh uh Sean chantanu how familiar are you
with Indian philosophy can we see videos
on them in the future so pretty familiar
and no and I answer I probably answer
this every single time with either
Indian philosophy or Eastern philosophy
which is just a mishmash of vast
cultural spheres or Islamic philosophy
there's there's a couple things to say I
don't need to do videos about everything
because there's other people doing
videos about about you know pick whoever
you want right you just got to do some
work and find them there are people who
do work on on Indian philosophy and
better than I would do so why would I
need to uh reinvent the wheel and do
crappier work when I could be doing good
work on philosophers who I actually know
much better
um
same thing with like you know Chinese
philosophy I don't I you know I don't
create videos on that other than from my
classes
uh because there's other people who do
better work and oftentimes I'll use
their videos instead of my own like
there's you know Brian Norton is out
there why uh van Norton why why the hell
should I try to do what he's doing when
he does it better there's also the the
language issue
um you know if I'm gonna tell you about
Cicero I can read Latin uh if I'm gonna
lead you through Descartes I can read
Latin which is what Descartes mostly
wrote in or French you know
um I don't read Sanskrit I don't read
Paulie I don't read uh these other
languages so why shouldn't I just leave
that to The Experts people are always
asking me to like go outside of my areas
of competence it's sort of like if I was
a great you know bass player I'd play
bass but not great and then people were
like
um why are you playing the bass why
don't you play play um the drums instead
because I'm not a drummer you know so
yeah all right
um
and this goes right to the next question
from Ken Haya do you cover advice to
philosophy as well no because other
people cover advice to philosophy right
uh so I don't need to to replicate their
their work
right here's a very interesting question
what are the red flags of a bad or
mediocre thinker
so I would say the biggest red flag
in my view is
off-base crappy takes of important
philosophers so when you see somebody
who clearly hates Aristotle or Kant or
you know pick whoever else and they're
saying all sorts of disparaging things
about them and you've actually read it
and you're like well that's not right
you know that that person either doesn't
know what they're talking about and they
probably relied on somebody else's
sources or they're they're actually
deliberately misrepresenting them in
which case uh why would you want to
engage with them so that that's a big
one right there
the need to present yourself as somehow
being the Pinnacle of philosophy in the
present you know like you're the you're
the one who's bringing everything
together in the vast system okay now
previous philosophers may have done
stuff like that
but they could have read a lot more of
what was available than is possible
right now so you know there's that I
would also say lots and lots of name
dropping you know
um
that's that's kind of a a red flag for
me
not that you shouldn't like cite sources
and stuff but
there's kind of an undo name dropping
that's more about getting oneself
prestige
um so those are those are some red flags
I would say
all right Lyndon good to see you here do
you have any interest in the popper [__]
fire abund uh discussions about
scientific epistemology not much I mean
I had to learn that stuff back in
graduate school to satisfy
um the uh one of four preliminary
examinations uh because we had a
epistemology philosophy of Science
examination so you had to read all that
stuff and you know learn something about
it
but I don't I don't really care that
much about those
those discussions not enough to have
anything interesting or competent to say
about it
um
let's see uh
it just jumped a little bit looks like
we have a lot of comments and questions
Right Said Fred said spinozaist
epicureans are the worst I'll have to
take your word for that because I don't
know any Spinoza's epicureans
um seems like those would be rightly
understood kind of at odds with each
other they wouldn't fit in very well
with each other not least because
epicureans are metaphysical pluralists
and Spinoza sure as hell isn't right so
um yeah I I I'm I kind of struggle to
think about
who would that who would fall under that
uh
and Olivia do you have any favorite
instances of a philosopher changing
their mind on an issue
favorite I don't know but I mean what
comes to mind
um well you know Wittgenstein very
famously
um moves from the track taught us where
he's closely aligned with the logical
positivists and then you know moves into
a whole different conception of of
things that you see in the philosophical
investigations and uncertainty but also
in the earlier remarks on the
foundations of mathematics
um and that's you know that's kind of a
famous example Nietzsche his assessment
of the birth of tragedy is is uh which
is his first major work very critical of
himself as being too hegelian
um
who else comes to mind I mean Kant talks
about breaking out of his dogmatic
Slumber now nobody reads his
pre-critical stuff these days but
there's there is a difference there
um
Aleister McIntyre right
Works in analytic philosophy and he's a
Marxist for a long time eventually moves
into
uh an Aristotelian framework and then it
becomes more and more robust with the
incorporation of augustinianism and
tomism so he'd be a good example yeah
those those are those are all
interesting uh examples Trevor says
could breaking down our narrative forms
of communication into sense of ternary
logic propositions help diminish the
level of Maya in society so Maya means
illusion it's a very big broad catch-all
thing
would breaking down our narrative forms
into sets of ternary three-part logic
propositions
diminish the level of Illusion or
mistaking or stuff I doubt it I think it
would generate more in part because
narrative forms don't neatly fit
um you know three-part syllogisms as a
matter of fact uh most things don't very
well you know even Aristotle when he
talks about syllogism there's syllogism
in that sense silly goosmos is actually
much broader
um
that includes other other modes of
argumentation as well and you know this
sort of a thing has been attempted in
the past you know you could think about
the failure of the logis project in the
early 20th century
um or you know structural attempts to
try to understand narrative and much
more sophisticated ways than just
um logical propositions but still trying
to formalize it they always break down
um language is way more complex than
that so I I don't see that as a uh
viable way of uh doing things
all right
um
JB Bell I'm disappointed to see stoicon
being in Florida but to make it
philosophical how do you decide whether
to boycott or just abstain from from
some system you find ethically
objectionable stoicon isn't in Florida
that's not stoicon that's another stoic
thing that they're doing I forget
exactly the name but it's it's not being
called silicon stoicon will be online
again this year as the modern stoicism
uh uh steering committee decided to do
in the last three years
um Andy and I are not going to be
running at this time around we're
passing it off and it looks like it will
probably be some some other people and
have some other themes but that's up for
discussion right now so you don't have
to worry you know there is a stoic thing
going on down in Tampa Florida which I'm
not going to either I mean to begin with
I have an event the night before here in
Milwaukee at the Women's Club in our
philosophy he eats thing so neither Andy
nor I would be hopping on a plane but
even if we were able to do it we'd have
to really think about whether the hell
we want to fly down to Tampa Florida you
know given what a
hot mess Florida is slouching into
becoming it's it's like just a cesspool
and you know we don't want to get
coveted either so if there's any place
where we're most likely to get it it
probably would be there so you don't
have to be disappointed about
missing that
um I think that's basically because you
know
um
one of the organizers uh Brittany palat
is is down there in in Tampa right
um I mean
and why boycott boycott means like
you're declaring I am not going to go to
this thing because of these Reasons I'm
going to you know I would normally go to
this but I'm not going to go to it
you just don't go to it like you say
abstain right
um I wouldn't I I don't think that going
down to Tampa or any place in Florida or
really almost any place in the American
South
is a great idea right now anyway
um you know we were actually scheduled
to go to uh Vegas and I'm so happy that
we're not doing that this year because
again I don't want to get on a plane if
I don't have to and
um deal with all sorts of people who
think that masking up is an irrational
fear-based thing to do rather than
something prudent so yeah I mean I will
be going to a conference here in the
summer just you know blocks from here at
Marquette
but I also like thought about should I
go to the
metaphysics conference in New Hampshire
at St anselms college and I said no I'm
not going to do that either you know I'm
going to wait and see for a little while
all right Lyndon uh says Nietzsche made
this observation about humans imitating
other humans to feel on the inside the
motives of others it's interesting
because recent research shows that
smiling affects emotions
yeah I mean that idea has been around
for a long time amazes is is something
that is morally relevant we could say
right uh we we learned this in Plato and
Aristotle and other thinkers so it's not
not that big of a surprise
CNC there's lots of talk recently about
the societal impact of new machine
learning Technologies even if these
systems aren't truly intelligent their
influence could be huge thoughts on this
yeah it's not even that they're not
truly intelligent they're not
intelligent at all
um there isn't any measure of
intelligence that they successfully
satisfy because they're not conscious
they're not learning because there's no
learning going on it's just doing
interesting algorithmic processes and
yes they will have massive impact on our
lives
um but we should separate these two
things out having big impact because
human beings conscious entities who have
agency decide to do things with them
yeah that's totally important and we
should be thinking about that a lot
but it's not intelligence it's nowhere
near it at this point and we're actually
going down the wrong uh Road I think
with machine learning uh or neural
networks you know there are some things
where we probably need to go back to
expert systems you know which was seen
as a dead end in AI about you know 15 20
years back
um
so yeah I think I think that's quite
right
um
oh JB has a follow-up there's a big
space between staying away from South
Africa and apartheid and people saying
you can't criticize the government if
you have social security and the like
yeah there and we should differentiate
between these these sorts of things I
think there's a lot of people who are
very sloppy in their thinking because
they're more enamored with either like
being a debate bro or they want to have
like total consistency about things like
I I have a friend who's kind of a boomer
type recently who
um you know wanted to bring up all sorts
of issues in a conversation with me
about he was worried about like college
education and being too woke and I was
like boy you should really spend some
time on campuses and a lot of these
worries that you have would go right out
the window just getting the college
students to actually pay attention to
what we're doing is tough and and
there's very few places where like the
woke people are are canceling you know I
mean most colleges are not Evergreen
college right and you know he was like
just you could tell the fear that he's
got and I'm like
what the hell is this to you I mean
you're not teaching college your kids
are are you know not being indoctrinated
why is it of such a big concern to you
and there's a lot of things where where
people have kind of inconsistent ideas
and allow themselves to be captivated by
them you know so
all right Rima have you ever read The
Works of oygen Fink uh what did you
think of him uh yeah I mean I've I've
read him a long time ago in graduate
school
[Music]
um
during a whiseral class
and I don't remember enough to really
say much about him you know so uh
clearly I wasn't impressed enough to
want to keep reading him
um but you know maybe that doesn't
necessarily say he's no good that just
means Greg 25 years ago didn't consider
him so
um
let's see
Alexander Olin is there intellectual
progress in philosophy it's
overwhelmingly accepted that Newtonian
physics improved on Aristotelian physics
are there similar instances of widely
accepted progress and philosophy you
will not find consensus uh among
philosophers about that I mean most
philosophers I would say in the present
don't have a very good you know
background in philosophies long and
complex history so they're not really
even competent to say anything about
that
um
but it's a mistake to think that
progress is exactly the same from
discipline to discipline to discipline I
mean I I think you can like look at
things and be like yeah I mean we don't
we don't propose ideas unless we're you
know crazy that like everything is water
you know so there's definitely I mean
Aristotle notes progress in his own time
in his works this is part of the
dialectical approach right so clearly
there is progress in some sense is it
the kind of progress that we see in the
Natural Sciences when the Natural
Sciences aren't like bullshitting or
making up stuff or stuff like that which
is some of the time by the way
um no it's a different it's a different
sort of progress one that requires you
to like step into the current and do
some work to be able to understand it
not just pick up you know a text as if
it's a piece of technology that you
could automatically start using right
all right
um
Gilgamesh says do you agree with the
reading of hegel's Science of logic that
he's attempting a presuppen
presuppositionless beginning to
philosophy
yeah but I find that completely
uninteresting
um and sure he's doing that in the
phenomenology too it tells you that
right but who cares I mean are we like
here so here's an example of progress
and philosophy are we like worried about
foundationalism at this point in time
and whether or not we're making any
assumptions
I mean you're going to make assumptions
you're gonna there's no presupposition
presuppositionless standpoint to begin
Philosophy from that was that was a pipe
dream
um and it's not even really needed you
know it's good to have axioms it's good
to have the
starting points you can still question
them but you got to start somewhere so
all right
um
let's see here
Rayman Hein I'm gonna go to university
this year what would be your advice for
a first year made philosophy major
student how can I learn to write better
philosophy essays well you get better at
writing in three ways
you read a lot and you read good stuff
right so you've got models and you see
how they're doing things you write a lot
and a lot of your writing sucks and you
just keep writing and you get better at
it right so probably start a blog and uh
keep that something separate from your
work that you're handing in for your
classes
now the third is you get other people to
look at your stuff and say well this is
good but you need to fix this or this
sucks and you need to you know actually
read the people you're opining about or
uh man you really should spell check
your stuff or don't write in gigantic
two-page long paragraphs break it up you
know so Reading Writing and and review
that's how your writing gets better
um and it works that way with speaking
and it works that way with with thinking
and other things too right You observe
other people doing it you do it yourself
you get you get criticism from people
um
now as as a first year philosophy
student yeah I mean don't put too much
pressure on yourself your first year
philosophy student don't think you have
to have an answer for everything you're
there to learn
not to try to come up with great ideas
of your own you know
um in the course of class and impress
your professors I mean you'll you'll
impress your professors the ones who are
worth impressing by actually doing
decent work you know and the level for
that is pretty low at the beginning
level and then it kind of UPS as you you
go along so
all right uh
ABI Manu says how to select a
dissertation topic and philosophy how to
start writing well you start writing by
starting writing right there is no way
around that and there is no recipe for
writing you write and you yeah Ursa K
leguin great author writing teacher she
you know says this in her essays about
writing that sooner or later you
actually have to do the work
now a dissertation topic
um that's up to you you figure out what
you're interested in uh you probably
would want to you know do some
preliminary research
um within a field and they're not going
to let you start a dissertation without
doing some preliminary research that's
why you write a prospectus
but you have to figure out what you're
interested in and again there isn't any
recipe for finding out a dissertation
topic I mean
it's um
there could be different problems I
remember people when I was in graduate
school and they're like I don't have any
idea what I'm going to write about and I
was like I got like five I got 15
different ideas here's three that you
could work with you know and maybe they
would they would be interested in one or
maybe they'd reject it or they would
modify it
um I've always got more ideas than I
have the time to write about but some
people have a hard time and and
sometimes it could be like you feel like
your mind is a blank spot one thing to
keep in mind is there's a lot of
pressure to like do original research
that's going to contribute to the
discipline
the odds of you actually pulling
something like that off in a
dissertation
are pretty low
most dissertations don't contribute
significantly to our understanding of
you know a great thinker concept or
problem and that's okay you know you're
you're not writing your master work when
you're writing a dissertation you're
doing something to satisfy a requirement
uh Luke mockery do you think there's
more to the difference between a comedy
and tragedy than just how things
conclude for the protagonist I mean
Aristotle says yes and it depends you
know in his case on like what kind of
protagonists do we have do we have a
noble person or a base person bass is
comedy Noble is tragedy so yeah there's
all sorts of different ways depending on
whose theory we're going to look at
about how comedy and tragedy would
differ from each other
[Music]
um
bicameral monk I understand he might
have a bit of a reputation but do you
enjoy any works from Charles Bukowski
you know I read Bukowski because
everybody was reading him and talking
about him and some people were imitating
him either in their writing or their
lifestyle when I was in college and
graduate school and I I gradually just
sort of concluded that
he's not for me
um I don't find what he's doing and
saying all that compelling
um I mean I think I probably rather if I
was going to pick somebody from that
time read Norman mailer than Bukowski
um
although mailer's probably a little
older than Bukowski
[Music]
um
but he had kind of like a fan base you
know
and
I just didn't find there was that much
there on his part you know
all right Jake like you lectures like
your lecture series and fiction work if
you were to do one on a TV series does
any show in particular come to mind
um well I've I've been thinking for a
while about
um doing a spin-off of the world to
speculative fiction series
that would be about TV or movie series
um
but the the shtick that I was looking at
originally was how how does it compare
to the the book series what what does it
take what is it depart from so like you
know there are no good versions of
Ursula Kayla Queen's Earthsea out there
but I could like look at the Studio
Ghibli and be like wow what a hot mess
this is you know or the bad sci-fi
version I haven't watched azimas
Foundation uh on Apple TV
but maybe that's good I don't know you
know but I thought about doing that and
I've also thought about
uh maybe doing some things on some
series on their their own as well but I
mean it's it's really a matter of having
the time to do it
so
all right
um
Alexander Olin I know you're into
figures and psychoanalysis like Freud in
the com but do you have any interest in
cognitive psychology or any of the
Contemporary quantitative approaches
um
quantitative approaches no because I
mean we already did that with
behaviorism way back in the day
um unless there's some massive
difference that that is going on there
cognitive stuff I mean I I talk about
that already you know CBT and rebt and
you know to to a certain extent uh DBT
um I think those can be useful sometimes
they're done poorly just as much as
psychoanalysis is often done poorly
um it really depends on on you know what
you're what you're doing with it
um not so big on positive psychology in
part because you know I see all the like
self-sampling that they have people
doing self-serving and I'm like well
this is not good data that they're
they're generating
um plus I kind of I don't like the
some of the assumptions I also you know
I think Victor Frankel's interesting too
you know you read like man search for
meaning that's cool that's kind of a pop
you know existentialist book you read
his actual serious works there's some
depth there you know so yeah
all right uh eliolanic have you read
Daria is on forgiveness
uh if so what are your thoughts on his
idea true forgiveness consists only in
forgiving the unforgivable I think it's
typical Dairy dot [__] you know
um I I you know I think darita cannot
resist making things like that phrase
you know and I I think that he's very
hit and miss
some of his stuff like his early work
can be very rigorous and thoughtful some
of it can just be like basically drivel
and then there's everything in between
um
I mean you notice I don't I don't rely
on him a lot for stuff and he's actually
somebody I thought about writing my
dissertation on at one time so you know
true forgiveness consists only in
forgiving the Unforgivable
I mean when are you going to use that
you know how is that a useful thing to
say to people when they're trying to
figure out whether or not they should
forgive something uh these these crazy
wild like on the extreme kind of cases
it just doesn't
that doesn't do much for me you know
um JB says thanks for the mention of
pure land I feel like Western people act
like we already know what that's like we
have Christianity yeah very very
different right
all right
um
let's see
donkey says uh so lucky to have four
channels of live great combos to be part
of this is the top she go to me uh well
thanks I'm glad that you you uh enjoy it
um
I hope you just skipped a little bit
let's see what we got here
uh oh donkey had a serious question
Green Bay's Packer Community ownership
bigotry seems to reflect something
rotten in society in the NFL what say
you
I don't I don't think that there's any
sort of bigotry involved in community
ownership it's a it's a model I don't
know why it would possibly be bigotry
and and doesn't represent something
rotten I mean you don't do anything with
your Packers stock we own Packers stock
you know I think we paid like 250 bucks
for a share you know so
all right uh
Trevor had a follow-up question about
the logical stuff are you overlooking
skillful tautological forms no because
tautological forms don't do [__] they're
tautologies you just say the the same
thing right unless there's some weird
sense of that that I don't understand
you know that people are are using the
the terms in
uh shrey the phrase that's subjective is
bandied about too much in every debate
discussion do you think it's unfair to
have a complete disregard for it there
are a lot of things that are going to be
subjective and objecting to them being
subjective is a sign that somebody's act
actually arguing in bad faith or doesn't
understand what the terms mean and you
know I would say this consider whether
it's actually worth spending your
valuable time debating with people who
say stupid things you know or whether
you should be spending that time on on
other people
uh ridicule do you have any examples of
philosophers you think butchered Plato
or Aristotle as in badly misrepresented
or misunderstood them I mean we could
come up with dozens including many
people in the present who I mean go to
an average philosophy conference and
listen to some analytic or Continental
tell you all about why Plato or
Aristotle is wrong you know and then
you're like well that's not in the texts
and Aristotle actually does answer this
here prime example of this would be
there was this big debate and discussion
and and uh
you know Aristotle Scholars who should
know better were involved in this like
you know Richard Kraut is you know
Aristotle's theory of friendship
egoistic or altruistic and you're like
well first of all Aristotle actually
addresses that not a Nico McCain ethics
book eight which is the only thing
you're reading but in the next book
where you know there's a whole
discussion of you know fill out toast
um self-centered self-loving you know if
you just read that [__] you wouldn't be
asking these dumb questions you know
um and then there's like you know you're
going to try to fit Aristotle into these
contemporary categories that that you're
particularly into and nobody else really
gives a [__] about outside of your
little circle you know there's a lot of
that that goes on with Plato and
Aristotle in in the present
um and then you know there's there's
good interpreters where you're like well
that's clearly not the case like you
know think about Leo Strauss and you
know everything's got to be esoteric and
what is the the real message that's
being said between the lines in Plato's
work and after a while you're like come
on
let's just read the friggin Play-Doh you
know
um you know obviously there's hacks like
Ein Rand who love Aristotle hate Plato
gets played all wrong gets Aristotle
wrong too right uh so there's there's
lots of of examples of people who get
that get you know mixed up
all right
[Music]
um
let's see Javier Bina here's an
interesting thing what are ways you
think Thomas gets Aquinas or Aristotle
for that matter wrong
coming to it with all sorts of
assumptions about what Thomas is
actually doing and being crappy readers
of Thomas himself that's where I think
it it very often goes wrong and then
making big assumptions like well Thomas
is basically Aristotle plus Christian
doctrine I mean all you got to do is
read the summit logia a while and you
realize that Thomas yes is bringing up
Aristotle and aristotelians like John
damaskeen and Alexander of aphrodisias
but he's also referencing uh authors
like Cicero and Seneca and boethius and
Augustine and you know draw ansem
drawing on them at different points so
he's got a very complex approach and I
think that a lot of Thomas are you know
they they want to use Thomas for
something the other thing too is they
they often are very schematic in their
reading of the history of philosophy so
you know they'll they'll get like
Kant becomes the big bad guy right you
know and you're like well that's
that's a take but it's not like the
right take on things so
Right Said Fred people who read
Spinoza's if he's an Epicurean uh I.E D
vardalakis and many other Americans
following him I doubt there's many other
Americans there's probably a handful
because I've never heard of this guy
um and uh
it seems like a pretty fringe thing you
know and why would you read spinozas if
he's an Epicurean why not read Spinoza
as if he's Spinoza you know
um all right so
let's see what else we got here uh Dr
Beavis come down to Huntsville Alabama
we would love to meet and talk with you
yeah I don't know that that's going to
happen anytime soon you know I'm not
doing a lot of travel uh certainly not
to to the redder States well uh kovid is
still in full force you know
um I'm immune compromised my wife is we
don't need that sort of sort of problems
you know
um
Ken says currently current very
currently very much enjoying reading
through volume 4 of stoicism today don't
have anything to add other than to say
thanks for editing it and taking part in
this creation yeah so Ken is is
referencing uh stoicism today selected
essays volume 4 which Leia goldrick and
I brought out in I want to say November
October
earlier last year
I don't know if we did we have it out
before stoicon maybe we did I don't
remember uh it was all kind of a blur to
me uh yeah that was that was a cool
project I think that the current editor
my friend and colleague Harold cavali
can he intends to continue the series
along with his assistant editor Judith
stove so you might see some further
Works coming out as well
um
let's see here
what else do we have
um
Alexander can you discuss the
correlation between the impressiveness
of beards and philosophical ability
there is no correlation
whatsoever at all so you know I I
wouldn't uh worry about that
um
oh Bilbo Baggins a friend of mine who
you know introduced me to philosophy of
friendship I would like to talk about it
with him in depth do you have any
starting points outside Aristotle and
Cicero which are good starting points
yeah Plato
um you know discusses it in the lysius
and then it comes up again in the
Symposium and in the phaedrus
um
there are some really great discussions
of it in Plutarch in various uh places
not just in his philosophical works but
in his biographies as well
um
you know
there's all sorts of
treaties on it throughout the
Middle Ages and early modern period here
and there but you kind of got to dig
around
and you know Mary wollstone crafts
Vindication of the rights of woman very
interesting discussion about why
marriage should be more oriented by
friendship than by erotic love
um Paul recruiter in the 20th century
has a book on friendship which you know
brings up people like Aristotle called
oneself as another
um darita of course has his politics of
friendship if you're into that sort of
thing so yeah there's all sorts of
interesting reference points that you
can you can go to
um it's it's an area that I I would like
to teach some sometime
all right
um
Trevor it can be good to have axioms but
is not necessarily an interesting
experiment can any humans learn to
reliably transcend axioms even for short
bursts of time uh transcend axioms
heuristics everything
um to me that's a completely
unattractive project if you want to do
that go ahead uh see where it gets you
um I don't I don't think that from where
I said it's it's a worthwhile project to
do
Forrest do you expect antenatalism to be
in a dictionary anytime soon I don't
know I don't I'm not the dictionary
writers I don't know how they decide
those sorts of things
um
let's see here
how much is it important to study read
the original text in Western philosophy
which text should I begin with so there
is no which text I should begin with
it's up to you I mean you can begin with
Plato if you want to that's a convenient
starting point you can begin in other
places there isn't like a
itinerary that everybody has to follow
in in philosophy and you should expect
to be going back and forth between texts
um and how important is it to study read
the original text I don't know do you
want to know what the the people
actually said and be confident that you
actually do know what they said or do
you want to rely on other people who
might be full of crap you know you won't
know whether they're actually reliable
or not if you read this history of
philosophy or this one unless you're
actually reading the original texts
um at least for some of the thinkers
doesn't mean that all you do is study
original text but why would you deprive
yourself of the opportunity of actually
reading Plato rather than reading
somebody else's stuff about Plato you
know
thank you
so um oh Lyndon says have you cooked
anything interesting or new lately I
haven't cooked anything new for for
quite a while I've got like a repertoire
of recipes that I tend to stick with for
the most part
um I mean I think many of you saw me
making the biscotti a couple weekends
ago and you know I took one batch to my
mother-in-law Shirley and one batch to
my my kid uh cat who by the way has I
you might have also seen this in social
media I she
she actually or they staged a reading
of a play that they wrote
which is kind of a big deal you know so
you can check out cat Sadler not Catt
but c-a-t and you can find her her play
uh what else
um so biscotti
uh have I done much cooking lately
my wife has been doing more of the
cooking because she you know we both
alternate and she really likes to get in
the kitchen
um I don't think we've done that much
Ellie I haven't done that much lately
but I'll probably be doing some more in
the future
um
do
[Music]
all right a lot of back and forth
between Trevor and other people
um
all right here's here's a new person
Lord Tennyson odd question is there any
children's literature you find engaging
or fun to read as an adult I think that
good children's literature should be
good literature in general for me it was
Narnia
yeah I mean
and Tolkien actually talks about this
and on on fairy stories saying yeah
fairy stories aren't really for children
per se
I mean I I did um I went back to the uh
Madeleine Ingalls time quintet and I
really liked that stuff and that's like
explicitly young adult stuff we covered
that in Worlds of speculative fiction a
couple years ago
um
I would like to reread Susan Cooper's
the darkest Rising series which had a
huge impact on me as an elementary
school uh kid really loved those and
maybe they'd be good again
um
read the Narnia books of of course to my
kids Louis Carroll's you know stuff as
well
um there is also a book
and I should find out who it's by and
um
called the horse the cat and the miracle
and
um
it is just a lovely
[__]
um
heard back it says here lesra giggy is
the the author and what an awesome
children's story uh that turned out to
be
um is there any other stuff
um
I mean I don't think I've read any other
children's lit for quite a while so all
right uh Sonny you mentioned behaviorism
earlier in the AMA do you have any
guesses why there are a few so few pure
behaviorists around yeah because it was
a failure
you know I mean I remember very
interestingly reading uh Beyond freedom
and dignity by Skinner and showing
mathematically in one of my classes why
none of this [__] could actually work
the way that he's presenting it
um you know
behaviorism so there were a couple
things that were wrong one was making
vast sweeping assumptions so as a
research project it was poorly founded
but you could say similar things about
you know cognitive approaches or you
know traditional psychoanalysis if
there's some there's some big
assumptions being made right it was also
kind of morally abhorrent the way that
they talked about and treated things and
I think that turns people off you know
and it turned out to be useful for some
things in a pragmatic sense but not to
be very true so that's probably it
um RT Whitby is The Logical conclusion
of believing in the existence of a
perfect God believing the existence of a
perfect world no
I don't think that you have to believe
if you believe there is a perfect God
and you got to figure out what you mean
by perfect because there's a lot of ways
of understanding that so it's not like
it's a simple concept
um
that doesn't entail a perfect world
so I you know I mean there are ways to
try to show it the Odysseys of sort I
mean you've got live Nets oh this is the
best of all possible worlds still
doesn't mean it's perfect it's uh yeah
um
mcblt gaming how many books a year do
you read I don't know
um and there's different kinds of
reading you know there's like reading to
do a book review there's reading to
teach which is often rereading in my
case there's uh reading for pleasure
there's reading to
consult certain chapters so I don't have
a clue and and I don't think that that
numbers like that really matter much
because what you're reading is is what's
more important right
um
donkey recipes do you make your own Mayo
no because I don't like Mayo
um I don't I don't I don't see why I
need to make it I stick to things I
actually enjoy uh Samuel thoughts on
kojav is an introduction to Hegel I mean
yeah if you want to understand kojev's
perspective sure if you want to
understand Hegel maybe you know you can
get some ideas from code Chev but you're
getting more kojav than Hegel when you
read him uh Alexander if you could
befriend any philosopher who would you
choose
that's a good question I mean because
who they are as a person is not
necessarily who they are in their Works
um who would I want to hang out with
I mean probably would be best for me is
hanging out with Anselm you know he was
a good guy
um
quite interesting quite engaging I
probably pick him but Renee Descartes
seemed to have been a pretty cool guy
too you know
um David Hume probably would have been
fun as well Mary Wollstonecraft you know
I'd love to have met her uh
quite a brilliant person
um so I don't know that's why that's a
good question
um
let's see who else do we have
um oops just skipped again
um
Chris says in between my first and
second read through of Aristotle's
categories I watched your core concept
videos got a great Foundation of
understanding now thanks yeah well
that's good
um
the categories is often the work that we
start people reading Aristotle with
it's kind of a bad idea but there isn't
any best work to start people reading
Aristotle with like an introductory work
apparently he did have a protracticus
but we don't have that anymore
um yeah the categories is is kinda
a mishmash of a whole bunch of different
topics and parts of it you're like what
in the hell is this guy saying right
sometimes it's a factor of the English
translation but sometimes it's also the
the overall idea
so yeah I'm glad that the videos were
helpful for that
um
let's see here lapse says any favorite
examples of atmosphere and Metal
not quite sure what atmosphere means
um
I mean there's definitely like different
feelings you could say to different
groups or albums right
like uh
you know think about like Venom's early
stuff where the sound production was
kind of uh low but it was very like
straight ahead they actually they didn't
call it black metal until the uh the
second
um album and if you look at like old
interviews with Chronos he's like you
know we play we play power metal speed
metal black metal you know it's just
like a whole bunch of strings of things
together but there was definitely an
atmosphere to those first three albums
Raven with their you know athletic rock
as as it got coined you know in the
first like four albums a great example
you know
um
so I I guess you could say there's a
whole bunch of of you know things like
that but I I I'd have to think about
what atmosphere is
all right uh deplorable Moran says
morian says I've been reading the
philosophical investigations I'm curious
your thoughts on wittgenstein's
reorienting philosophies therapeutic
exercise for those Tangled in language I
think that that was the sort of thing
that Wittgenstein and his his uh
contemporaries needed but it's
definitely not all there is to
philosophy and it was really silly for
people to pretend that that was like
that's what philosophy is and does you
know
um vitkin show is more like a cul-de-sac
than an Avenue
it's a cool place to go to but uh and
then you can make some uses of some of
his ideas but you spend a lot of time
kind of spinning your wheels with him in
the philosophical investigations
and Dan I mentioned you know uh lectures
are the uh uh
what is it is it lectures on foundations
of mathematics it's definitely
foundations of mathematics and then
uncertainty there's a lot of like
Wittgenstein just kind of like going
around and trying to figure stuff out uh
and then people took that as like well
that's what philosophy should be like
you know
um so yeah
um
bullet Mao says can we spot
cryptomnessia and differentiate them
with references when reading a book I
don't know what crypto uh Messiah is I
mean it would suggest
hidden memories or something uh
um but I don't I don't know what the
term actually signifies so all right
Julian how familiar are you with Renee
Gerard's memetic theory if you're
familiar what do you think of that yeah
we read Gerard back in grad school and I
thought he was an interesting thinker
you know
um the idea of memetic Desire I think is
very useful
um I think that's that's quite true and
he articulated something interesting and
and uh applicable you know
all right uh RT Whitby what do you think
about the ca being involved in the
assassination of JFK many of the JFK
researchers think that they were I don't
really give a [__] about the JFK
assassination
um I you know it's funny I I had a time
back in graduate school where this
professor who you know was a boomer and
was actually from Canada but it lived a
lot of his life in the U.S was trying to
tell me about like how the CIA and the
mafia and all these people were involved
and I was like
I mean I don't really care he's like how
can you not care it was a revelation
that our government was corrupt and you
know was lying to us and I was like well
who the hell doesn't know that you know
I I get how like for
True Believers and Camelot and all that
it could have been uh a real wrenching
experience but I mean
at this point in time why do we care
um it's it's not as if there haven't
been conspiracies before you know
um so yeah all right uh
donkey didn't know of your mayowa
version I don't have a mayowa version I
just don't like mayonnaise you know
um
so I'm not and and by the way this sort
of thing like the oil emulsifies before
the eye you can use any ingredients I
don't do Boutique cooking I do like
plain old Straight Ahead this is going
to taste good kind of stuff I'm not into
Frou Frou [__] you know my wife worked
at The Culinary Institute of America so
I got to see all the Molecular
Gastronomy you know essentially you know
culinary masturbation deconstruction all
this kind of stuff I'm not into that I'm
not impressed by that sort of thing I
don't find it compelling I would rather
like make a good loaf of bread or you
know good uh stew or something like that
and get it done and start eating and get
back to the stuff that I really want to
do you know
so
all right uh Lyndon what secondary
thinker or thinkers of nature are you
into the debate over what he was saying
is quite wide and so on
um yeah that's a good question so I mean
I do like to lose his uh nature book
um I mean I don't think with with any of
the interpreters of Nietzsche I'm going
to say this
I don't go to them because I want like a
completely accurate understanding of
Nietzsche I go to them because they take
Nietzsche in interesting places on their
own
so you know Heidegger's got these great
Nietzsche lectures which are sort of
like kojav and and uh Hegel right you're
getting a lot more uh Heidegger than you
are necessarily Nietzsche same thing
with the loses stuff
um but I don't spend a lot of time
reading secondary lit you have to
understand I I you know time is limited
and unless I'm doing like
academic work where I need to
bring in interpreters and say well this
person's
write about Aristotle this person's
wrong I'm not usually spending much time
reading other people's stuff on these
you know
so
um
all right uh
make BLT gaming why don't philosophers
get more involved with politics and
shaping our society
um yeah sounds like a great project for
you I don't why don't you
get involved as a philosopher and
structuring the society or if you're not
a philosopher try to make some openings
for philosophers in politics and shaping
our society because there isn't a hell
of a lot of room for it right
um it's not easy to get involved in
politics
um
so that's probably the answer right
right there you know
[Music]
um
all right uh bullet crypto Menace is an
implicit memory phenomenon which people
mistakenly believe a current thought or
idea is a product of their own creation
when they've encountered it previously
and forgotten it okay well
um and what did what was asked
originally can we spot cryptomonesia and
differentiate them with references when
reading a book
um I mean
I don't know I never I've never thought
about this not not not really an issue
for me because you know I don't assume
that I'm coming up with the ideas that
are being articulated in a book and
being like that author stole from me you
know Emmanuel Kant is saying the things
that I I you know have said so who does
this happen to
um
you know uh I guess I guess it happens a
lot when people steal other people's
stuff you know like in business settings
when your boss
here's your great idea and then passes
it off as their own and thinks that they
actually came up with it but are there a
lot of people doing that with philosophy
books I I don't know so all right uh
let's see here
lapse for a Continuum there's a
there's one word in here that's doing a
lot of work you seem to be very
disciplined in making good use of your
time hoping to develop that skill more
myself so seem is doing a lot of work
there
um you know I I screw off uh like other
people do there's days where I've you
know I'm gonna do this and I'm gonna do
this and I'm gonna do this and then very
little of it actually gets done
um
so you know like the closer you actually
get to the Greg Sadler who is not you
know the person in social media or in
YouTube but is the guy living here in
this apartment with with his wife
um the more I think you see him not
getting things done you know
um you know watching TV longer than he
should or
um
you know
not not getting to all the projects that
he sets himself sleeping in you know all
those sorts of things so but I mean life
is like that I mean when I get done with
this I gotta go and like take a load of
laundry and put it in the dryer and then
you know eat a little something and get
ready for the next event and then think
about what else I'm gonna do during the
day so yeah seem all right so Ken now
Ken is also you should you should note
somebody who knows a lot about Metal uh
when Scott to really and I were doing
our classic metal class Ken was was a
very frequent attendee who has a lot to
say so uh for atmospheric metal I'd
strongly remember
recommend the first four Priest albums
highly experimental for their day I'd
have an atmosphere of futurism about
them in many of the tracks and I would I
would second that
um and so what are the first four Priest
albums Rock arola which has some really
great stuff on it some some priest fans
are like yeah it's not as good as the
other albums they hadn't quite found
their way but I remember getting it as a
teenager and putting it on the turntable
and being like holy [__] this is awesome
stuff you know you got rock and roll
itself with this wonderful fantasy of a
you know rock and roll a woman for a
rock and roll a man you know and then
you've got like these
atmospheric pieces like caviar and maths
and winter and some other classic uh
works on it then you got Sad Wings of
Destiny a lot of great ones on that and
then my favorite Priest album sin after
sin the third album
really awesome stuff you know
um
from the very beginning all the way to
the end and then stained class that is
also a great album and you can hear them
getting harder and heavier on that
particular album
um there's also a great cover of better
better by you better than me Spooky
Tooth did it originally and Priests then
did it after that so yeah so that's a
good suggestion and you could say the
same thing with like the first five well
actually six Iron Maiden albums you know
the first two of them are
the compositions
I mean it's all virtuosic but there's
kind of an openness in them
um in the in the sound in the production
you know uh and then you got number the
Beast and peace of mind and Power Slave
and that's all kind of like in one big
progression they've got a new singer who
winds up being you know the the one of
the best singers in metal Bruce
Dickinson
um Steve Harris is still doing most of
the writing and then you get somewhere
in Time where some people thought they
kind of lost their way but I think that
stood the test of time so
all right TM uh after finishing wool
Durant's study of civilization what do
you think would be a good continuation
after Napoleonic age where Durant sadly
signs off
I wouldn't rely on Durant much Durant is
kind of a popularizer who's plays fast
and loose with stuff
um I would uh
maybe go back and read some
other historians than than Durant you
know
all right uh
Milan says I enjoy your content glad to
read that I'm happy that you you do
um you know and I I'm gonna say
something because there aren't any other
questions here right now that so I've
been doing the YouTube thing now since
well the spring of 2011 and so now it's
about 12 years
um
and you know I'll definitely be doing it
through the rest of the 2020s I don't
know what YouTube is going to look like
come 2030 if it's even going to be
around or you know what's going to
happen with it but
you know I enjoy doing that content
production I've produced now about I
think 2500 videos total
um
and some of them are not as good as
others you know when I especially in
terms of like production stuff uh you
know I just plunk down a flip Cam and uh
you know record stuff without a mic and
uh that didn't always come out great
sometimes the lighting would be a little
inconsistent
um but it's it's good and and I'm really
glad that the technology was there
because you know when I first started
doing
um
YouTube actually before I even started
it you know my my wife Andy was like you
should try doing this upload your stuff
and I was like well who who's going to
want to watch my crap you know well as
it turns out you know a lot a lot of
people you YouTube was a great equalizer
you could be at a very low tier
institution be kind of a nobody and you
know people might still if the content
fits their needs they'll uh they'll
still watch it so you know that's great
donkey's got a reminiscence here I think
it was 2012. I know the depression video
was impact and caring and sharing and
inspiring so I I get I did that that
long ago I've been meaning to do an
update about that like well where am I
where you know back then I was still
taking Wellbutrin where am I today and I
can say I'm less depressed than I was
then but I still have to watch it you
know there's Tendencies towards it so
all right uh lapse nine Continuum as
long as the Greg who is home with his
wife is happy I suppose it's what
matters most yeah because you know this
is this is kind of a good observation
about
um online presence right used to be in
the old days we would say Facebook isn't
real life or Twitter isn't real life
well it's pervaded into our lives you
know we now live in this weird digital
we you know there's we're living in an
analog setting but there's all this PR
what would you call penetration of the
digital into our lives and we're kind of
weird hybrid creatures nowadays
um but we do need to have a basis as
they say you know touch grass so it
doesn't have to be grass it could be
touched the couch or touch the windows
or things like that
um
all right we're gonna get we're getting
well we're at we're at the end of our
time I'll answer a few more questions
Brock says what works for Motorola would
you recommend it seems difficult to find
many copies or where to start on
mainstream book websites
so one of the works I would recommend by
history is not a book but it's rather an
encyclopedia entry that he wrote he uh I
think it was for Encyclopedia Britannica
he wrote an entry on phenomenology so
you got like one of the most important
phenomenologists explaining what he
thinks phenomenology is for a
non-academic
um public
that's whenever I teach phenomenology or
if I'm teaching like contemporary
philosophy and orienting it towards
Continental I include that piece
um I think the Cartesian meditations are
pretty accessible
um and they're fairly short so that can
be quite good to begin with as well with
glycerol
um and then you know that'll at least
like get you started right
so
all right uh milahan philosopher's
Corner what advice would you give a
philosopher who gets harassed for
studying philosophy
um it depends on where you're being
harassed who's harassing you why you're
being harassed
um I mean is it like you know walking
down the hall and people are like hey
nerd and they knock the Heidegger book
out of your hand uh that's one kind of
thing if you're like getting in people's
faces and telling them that the
unexamined life is not worth living that
they're living unexamined lives you
might be bringing a bit of that on
yourself I I don't know your situation
so you know I don't know that I have a
lot of advice to to give about that
[Music]
um
and then uh here's one other from
millihan any advice for a philosophy
blog startup yeah write a lot
um and uh don't necessarily release
everything that you write you know the
blog is is up to you to do with what you
want uh milahan people who troll me and
say it's a waste of time okay so if it's
online trolling block those people
who says that they have to have a voice
in your spaces
I look at all so this is a great place
to end I'll say um
I look at my YouTube channel I look at
my social media as being like my front
porch
people can come on it and have
conversations with me and with each
other but if they act like [__]
they're getting kicked out you know and
I don't like give people a lot of uh you
know I'll give people a second chance
but they're probably not getting a third
chance if they're acting like a jerk
because they're not worth my time and
they don't have to be worth your time
either so if uh people are trolling you
and you don't like what they're saying
block them you know if you're in Twitter
or you're an Instagram or Facebook or
whatever else there's mechanisms for
that sort of thing you know you don't
have to engage with them engage with
people who are going to have productive
conversations with you you know and then
the same thing goes for like
face-to-face stuff if you've got friends
and your friend group are like yeah
philosophy is just a waste of time it's
you know we should be like out there
partying or something like that well
then you got you know you might want to
pick some different friends
um and sometimes it can be difficult to
make friends but
that's uh that's the way it works in
life you know you get better at it sort
of like writing you get better at it the
more that you do with it so
all right uh I am going to say
um
goodbye to everybody well there's a nice
one from Donkey you may not realize how
nice a few minutes have grown up talking
is uh yeah I mean
especially like let's say you're
bringing up little kids or something
right there's a lot of people who wind
up uh uh starved for as we call it adult
conversation so all right thanks for all
the great questions and comments and um
I'll see you next time we've got some
other stuff coming up this uh this month
that's cool next uh
um
Saturday we've got worlds of speculative
fiction we're talking about The Witcher
series uh sapkowski's stuff that'll be a
lot of fun and
um what else have we got I'm trying to
produce a self-directed study video on
Descartes uh which might be helpful for
some people and you know we've got some
various other things here and there so
all right I'll see all of you and uh
we'll uh meet up somewhere else in the
ether